j'étais mal le ps le parti c'est lille
ça fait de bons scores pour ces
sénatoriales comment analysez vous ces
résultats de façon plus générale c'est
un coup de semonce pour emmanuel macron
c'est d'abord une défaite
je rappelle que monsieur patriat a plus
qu en marche on nous annonçait la
victoire éclatante au sénat ne l'est pas
le cas puisque c'est une défaite en rase
campagne pourrait macron et ses troupes
pour le parti alice est une vraie
résistance puisque par rapport au
résultat de 2014 municipales on devait
avoir moins de sénateur mais on a vu que
ce sont des avions des candidats sur le
terrain qui ont travaillé on sait
bénéficier des mesures catastrophique
qu'annoncé emmanuel macron concernant
les collectivités locales et donc notre
groupe est le deuxième du sénat ce qui
était notre objectif nous avons atteint
est donc maintenant nous devons avoir un
groupe qui sera combatif qui sera encore
c'est de proposer et de porter une
politique
alors justement qu'est-ce qui est le
plus coûté à la république en marche
lors de ces élections c'est la colère
des élus locaux qui a vraiment joué
quand vous n'êtes pas que pas seulement
s'il ya quatre mois quatre mois de
politiques sociales désastreuses
la baisse des coûts du pouvoir d'achat
jusqu'à la loi travail puis vous avez
aussi sur les collectivités les
associations qui a moins dans la
campagne j'ai rentré beaucoup
d'associations qui concrètement vont
devoir fermer leurs portes parce que non
en plus de contrats aidés on ne peut pas
être la chambre des cantons
aussi les collectivités ne pas porter ce
message là donc le voilà donc la plus
con marche a fait un choix
au début c'était ni droite ni gauche
finalement cette boutique de droite donc
ils sont aussi ils sont maintenant ils
se sont tapés face aux réalités